well hello everybody and welcome to this
weekly podcast thing that I'm doing
where I chat with two wonderful friends
about the most recent episode of The
Last of Us TV show today I'm joined by
Trisha who are you sorry you just took a
sip I did I just took a sip but that's
okay hi everybody
um yeah I'm uh I'm Trisha I do mostly
Tech and video game stuff online and I
stream in my spare time when I'm not on
set and I love it and I'm obsessed with
the last of us uh Series right now so
Alana thank you for having me here to
talk about it I'm super stoked thanks
for being here uh Steve who are you yes
hi I'm Steve I'm a comedian and wacky
boy and I've got a podcast with my
friend Mike falzone that I do call
Dynamic banter and I've worked with
Trisha before yeah and I've worked with
you before and we're all friends here we
worked together before yeah
okay
we probably have that seems likely and I
just forgotten about it yeah I mean like
probably some kind of Smosh [__] try
to eat a garbage can yeah challenge
you're probably right that seems like
something dude Steve works on a lot of
different things
that's why I'm saying yeah because maybe
I spoke out of turn maybe we haven't
done a thing statistically we have I
don't know yeah yeah we are we have a
separation of Kevin Bacon though
that's true he's the one who combines
the soul yes exactly he's the glue
um so today we are talking about episode
two
of The Last of Us HBO show um and I
wanted to start obviously with the very
start of the show which I thought was
absolutely brilliant
um the actors in Indonesia I believe
they're in Jakarta specifically I don't
remember exactly
um we have the police basically going to
detain a woman who is a scientist
working at a university biologist taking
her to show her uh the first example
they have of an outbreak uh how did
everybody feel about that particular
scene Trish you want to go first
it was so scary okay so I right away
when they got her I was like oh she's
not in trouble she's an expert in
something which they quickly confirmed
in the vehicle the glasses during
transport
um but yeah it was it was so wild I mean
the scene where she's doing the autopsy
I don't know about you guys but I was
like oh it's gonna come to life like
it's going to turn into a runner right
there like especially when she put her
fingers in the mouth I was like it's
just gonna Chomp on the gloves no bullet
in the head we should be good because
from what we know of the lore in both
the series and the game the fungus can't
live or it needs it needs a Live host
right so it can't the fungus can't stay
alive in a dead body yeah
um but yeah then when like the the new
thing they're doing with the fungus
coming out of the mouth is just
terrifying but also that scene confirmed
a major theory about the origins of the
fungus but I will not get into that
because I want to hear what Steve
thought of it yeah let's jump into that
I loved the opening of this episode it
feels like Chernobyl
right because it is the crater right or
whatever this yeah yeah uh but I like
it's it's it seems like a perfect
subject for him to jump into with uh
with the last of us but yeah I uh I love
I love the backstory stuff I was talking
to someone earlier about how uh you know
we we don't need to know where it comes
from we don't need to know you know the
game kind of gave us little hints or
whatever but we never really found out
where it started because it's not
important
um and I was talking to someone who who
felt strongly about that being you know
part of the show too but they were kind
of upset that
um we're kind of seeing the origins of
it sort of but but um I like it I like
it in this case because they're doing it
in an elegant way not really like a fan
servicey like uh
um
forced way yeah I think maybe in TV you
actually need a little bit more of that
backstory for the TV audience though the
mediums are different you have to change
things between TV and video games and I
think there are probably some things in
the game that wouldn't fly like I expect
we're going to see a lot less as we did
in this episode of people being shot or
people being the problem because I think
that's a lot more confronting when it's
in the TV World
um but yeah this opening I some movies
and TV shows have these little chunks
that you're like if I took that out and
it was a short film it would be one of
the best I've ever seen and I felt that
way about this start to finish and
ending with what's your suggestion and
she says bomb and then what are you
gonna do and she's like I just want to
be with my family is such a good way to
hit home that that person is so strongly
convinced of what they're saying like it
gave me chills that she's like I just
want to be with my family while you bomb
this city uh because as Trisha alluded
to the uh the flower uh confirmed the
theory that the flower is effectively I
guess it would have been wheat crops
that probably got infected with the
fungus and that's what infected Mankind
and yeah I just thought it was beautiful
such good acting across the board there
like the pacing of that and you're right
the tension of like being like well if
this were a cheaper thing they would
have had the jump scare with that body
on the table but I was like you know
what I'm nervous but it's HBO I was like
they're probably not gonna do it and
you're right that Trish that again it
shouldn't happen because I think this is
establishing the same thing as the games
that they can't exist outside of um a
live body but it was still like just so
chilling and the stakes there I I loved
it I thought it was so fantastic and
then I think immediately we cut to that
shot of Ellie on the grass with the sun
beaming down if I'm correct I'll
improved that moment because you feel
like wow they're in a [__] beautiful
Forest somewhere totally they found a
nice little camp and then I also went
real pretentious with it or I was like
in my head I was like you're talking
about a bomb and how you want to be with
your family and then it's a sun beaming
down on the lone child who might be able
to save the world and I was like did
they I don't know that's how I took it I
was like oh dude beautiful there's so
much symbolism and I think even the fact
that it was a reveal that they're in a
building was so beautifully done because
you're like all right we're outside I
guess but no you're you're in the
buildings that uh I seem to remember
kind of being in in the video game it's
been a while but I feel like we went
into that museum for sure oh as soon as
they mentioned the museum I was like is
the test is that is it happening is it
going down now oh yeah both the museum
and the hotel and I feel like much like
in the first episode there were some
side by side shots taken directly out of
the game from the lighting there was one
shot that I haven't looked to see if it
was exactly in the game but there was a
shot where Tess is looking back at Ellie
after Joel is has already left that
building and Ellie's still in the
building right after the whole chicken
sandwich thing which was hilarious okay
but how did the chicken not go off
right does she have ice packs that was
over a day old
yeah she's eating I mean I feel like in
this post-apocalypse you're like you
take what you can get if the chicken can
last a little longer because when are
you gonna get chicken again but if it
makes you [__] yourself Steve
I know that's the last thing you want in
a world where you can't just go to the
CVS and get Pepto-Bismol it's half the
shits what do you do I don't know no I'm
sorry I cut you off for a really stupid
point there Trish please continue
that's true as well I thought this as a
mom that packs lunches now I was like
where's the ice pack you can't pack
chicken
um but at the same time understood Joel
and Tessa's uh you know being being a
little jealous of the chicken definitely
when they had their jerky um but it was
just there were some really beautiful
shots that I did feel like were lifted
right out of the game and I know we'll
get to it in a bit but particularly when
we get to the hotel I was like this is
an exact Recreation almost
um but yeah I agree the whole episode
was done beautifully Alana I didn't get
that moment where it was like bomb
everything to the child
but I love that now that you said it I
might have been reading because I don't
know but I know I do feel like they
often frame her in the light which I
again like like Steve said there's a lot
of symbolism it's just like making sure
that you're aware that she's in theory
the the precious uh
cargo I guess that they're treating us
as but we did see a lot of development
on that in this episode like how do you
guys just broadly feel about how tests
was represented here before the end oh
man I thought she was I I mean you know
I everyone's well not everyone but some
people were like oh that's not how she
goes in the video game that's not what
happens to her I don't think it can
happen the same way no I don't think so
either I don't think a lot of things can
happen the same way like I'm actually
kind of relieved we didn't get like a
giraffe
because I think it's just not earned yet
in the in like if you've never played
the video game you have no idea that's
gonna happen you know and uh if it
happened in the show so early on I would
be like oh man they're just like forcing
all this fan service stuff but I'm glad
they're leaving out things and changing
things like the uh the tendrils in the
mouth okay well I hate that I hate it
interesting yeah it's gross creepy or
you hate it because
symmetry the sorry that the symbolism of
it bothers me like just the way that it
looks coming out of my mouth is I hate
it because it's creepy but we're jumping
ahead a little bit the thing I didn't
like about this episode that I think a
lot of people maybe didn't love was the
the choice of a kiss
um with Tess uh felt very odd to me I
wasn't sure why they did that um I'm
assuming it was to like get her
connected immediately but then it
clearly didn't work because she was
still able to consciously look down and
drop the lighter um it just was odd it
was odd to me I felt I agree a bit
weirded out by it I don't feel like it
added I'm not I'm not entirely sure why
it was there and I know that they have a
loss of us podcast but I'm currently
opting not to watch that until the
show's done because I didn't want to
like get get too much Insight yet like I
was like yeah I'll watch that after I
finish watching the show so I'm not
influenced by it I'm sure they have the
verification are you watching the little
like after behind this I didn't even
know there were until I saw it neither
did I say that today oh yeah there are
and they go into why they made that
choice a little bit but I don't want to
spoil it for you yeah I read a thing to
watch that yeah I also read a thing
where they kind of confirm what that is
yeah go ahead you could tell me plays
Tess who did an amazing job I think um
which by the way Steve I know you're a
huge leftovers fan did you recognize her
you know what I it took me two episodes
to realize it's not Carrie [__] from The
Leftovers
okay Trisha I was so there with you I
was like I love the leftovers I love
Carrie [__] so much and I'm like she's
so good in this show and then I'm like
wait a minute that's not her it's just
someone that is like looks exactly like
her they could be sisters I so mean
the first two episodes up until this
morning right I was like me too I was
convinced he was doing such a great job
and then I was like like in the lap Wade
yeah yeah she's so good though she is
very good and I think that um this is
one of the things that I realized
watching episode one that I feel like
the TV show could do differently that I
as a video game fan who thinks that
video games need to stop trying to be
Hollywood because video games are great
why do we need to be you um I was like
oh you can kind of flush things out a
little bit more in a way I didn't expect
and with Tess I feel like they did flesh
her character out a little bit more or
it's just that I'm not remembering well
enough to say I'm playing to start
replaying the game tonight actually but
I know it's been I literally I've never
gone back to the game I played it when
it came out and I absolutely adored it
and I played the sequel and absolutely
adored it and I just I've never I
haven't gone back to the first one so
imagine that's all the game stuff is
fuzzy it's kind of nice though like
obviously like I said I knew when they
were heading to that building that were
very much expected tested I feel like is
great for us as video game players where
you get the tension of oh my God she's
going to die especially because I think
I felt maybe a little bit more attached
to this version of test two she was a
little bit more maternal she seemed a
little bit softer I'm not really sure if
again I'm I'm just remembering but I
really really liked the portrayal of
Tess and uh the desperation like you
know watching her knock those cans over
um I just like that whole scene was was
fantastic but also just being the person
to really like forced Joel to go ahead
with all of it is something that was
previously established but I felt like
she really again fleshed out Tess's
character in a way I really liked it
yeah she also really had a good
connection with Ellie yeah that is
something that we didn't really get to
see in the game and I did just get to
replay okay so I'm right she was she did
seem more caring
yeah I would agree with that um also
she's like she's a super badass in both
but in different ways
um she's a little bit more
um in the game I feel like she's a
little bit more of a Bruiser if you will
a little bit more hardened yeah um and
even though Tess in the series is still
very hardened we see like you said like
that more maternal kind of instinct that
more she does have hope for Humanity
come out when she finds out what Ellie
could mean for Humanity yeah and I
thought that was portrayed really
beautifully yeah
um but yeah I just got to replay the
game because my husband is not much of a
gamer and I knew that the last of a
series was being made and I was like oh
babe you gotta play this game before the
series comes out so I watched him play
through it that's start to finish just
recently to like relive it for myself so
a lot of the stuff is very similar but
then added two in beautiful ways like
Tessa's character like we're talking
about it doesn't feel like a huge
deviation but in addition to me at least
in it so far I I actually like I feel
like there was only one moment with the
Tess Ellie thing that felt kind of like
unnatural to me the the way that Ellie
reacted so I think you're going to say
the same thing that I'm having to leave
test there okay like not the same thing
it seemed really like she was like
freaking out that they had to leave her
there like no we can't leave right I did
out loud say you just met him yeah Not
only was it did you just meet her she
was like you know
there was a moment when
um they're having their back and forth
before the chicken sandwich and
um Joel is pointing his gun at Ellie and
um Ellie's of being like a smart ass and
then Tess says did you notice that he
was gonna kill he like wanted to kill
you a second ago or something like she's
like not behaving like
you know and then right after that she
says I'm gonna treat you like an adult
I'm gonna talk to you like an adult and
so she's like treating her like an adult
the entire time it feels like so it's
like she's not I feel like they aren't
getting like a natural Connection in the
show like she's this kind of like you
know they're there she's a protector to
Ellie she knows that but other than that
it didn't feel like they got to know
each other well enough for her to be
like no we can't leave her there it felt
like way too much I I said the same
thing out loud and and the way that I
was able to justify it which I agree it
doesn't come across like they're like
good friends or anything no was that in
theory Ellie up to this point hasn't
seen that happen to somebody I don't
know but that's what I kind of assumed
was that Ellie has not been in a
situation before of having to leave
another human behind which is a horrific
thing to do rather than it being
personal about tests and that's the
thing that I love about this that I am
reappreciating is like all of the stuff
that you get to see LEC for the first
time and not have Tech stuff like asking
about hotels I think that like that's so
well done and done without Exposition
and I just that's what I imagined that
that was was again I made a joke about
it when it happened but I was like I
feel like that's we can't leave a human
behind oh my God this is scary rather
than no Tess you were so kind to me yeah
I guess it feels like we've got a
version of Ellie that's like seen a lot
of [__] by this point like probably
she's old enough that she's seen like
some pretty terrible [__] out there so
it felt like this is kind of par for the
course in a nightmare world where you
sometimes have to leave people behind
you know it's true I would think in
addition to the it being so awful to
leave someone behind she has no
connection at this point with Joel right
like her connection of the people that
were taking her through
seemed like it was primarily with Tess
and Tess did just say like Joel's
totally willing to shoot you by the way
yeah so I kind of felt like that moment
of like no not to stuck with him now I'm
stuck with him
yeah that's true there are people in
chat saying what about left behind and I
guess left behind that stuff certainly
does happen
um but I I think that uh I wasn't sure
necessarily if left behind was Canon I
know that um Malin mentions Riley I
think in episode one but like I know I
know it's kind of for the games I didn't
know if it had happened in the TV yeah
that's a good point we don't know if
that's canonical in the show no I don't
it looks like they might go there it's
looking like they might because if they
do then that kind of would make sense
from a character perspective of her
losing more people around her that she's
developing kind of sure yeah
relationship PTSD type thing yeah yeah
um so outside of like Tess's character
another thing that I felt like we saw a
lot of in this episode that I just loved
was the outdoor environments like
you know the first time they walk out
and you see that toppled building and
you also kind of see it from Ellie's
perspective they look so good like I can
kind of recognize that it's CG but I
can't recognize that well where it
starts and where it ends I just feel
like the world almost in some cases like
you said how you can see things side by
side I feel like the world has a lot of
that where you see it side by side like
of that particular sequence you'd
probably look identical in the game it's
just so goddamn good looking like it's
beautifully attention to detail like all
of the sets the Interiors I was just
blown away by seeing more of the outside
world this time and just how goddamn
pretty and and terrifying it looks yeah
and the the clickers all like on the
ground like wiggling around out there
like that was like a terrifying thing to
see like I don't remember them looking
like that in the game ever like where
they're like all swarmed and wiggling on
the ground like that that was that's the
thing right now they're a swarm yeah now
they're all connected which is a new
another new thing that like they're all
connected and uh if there's a fresh
Spore in the ground they can like use it
as like a telephone basically I imagine
yeah we're in trouble I imagine that's
the answer to them not being spoils
right um yeah without the spoils you
have to have like just a kind of
different expression of how everything
travels and I looked up actual cordyceps
this morning which I mentioned Google
searches for that have gone way up
because I was curious about how it was
and I guess it's a fungus that usually
does infect um insects and like if you
see images it does kind of do the same
thing the the creepiest one that I saw
was a tarantula that was affected by it
um but they also they basically overtake
a host body force it to go somewhere
warmer so that they can Thrive and then
they'll kill it and then let spores out
so spores actually are a part of how it
works so I was like well they had to
take that out of the show for a bunch of
reasons that I think most people
understand that's obviously the biggest
departure from the games but I feel like
taking the sports that makes sense right
or either of you against that decision I
kind of want to talk about it because I
don't I don't I don't let's talk about
it because I don't see a reason to not
do the Spore thing because I mean maybe
we'll get like the gash gaseous ones
that like let out the poison I mean
remember the one that would like let out
spores and you'd have to letters which I
think they established is not real in
this episode she like I guess or they're
like it's a rumor or something yeah or
maybe yeah if they were like that
doesn't exist and then and then Ellie
references The Click is because she's
never seen one before yeah and they say
they don't comment what I thought
happened in that scene at least well
because yeah because I feel like the no
comment means that maybe they've seen
some of those things but they didn't
want to scare her that's what I feel too
weird about them and that was just
foreshadowing of a bloater we might see
later I thought their reaction to blodus
was like haha no but then when she was
like what about the ones with the
exploited faces
and then they were like yeah maybe
that's the yeah that's what I thought
but I could be wrong maybe someone in
now I love that oh they said there's one
in the trailer if there was I completely
missed it so make sure yeah I didn't
watch any of the trailers I wanted to go
in without any visuals like I just kind
of want to experience this show as it
goes
um well sorry for the spoiler that's my
bad how dare you no no no no I don't
care about that I played the game did we
confirm there are bloaters in the
trailers I didn't know if there were I
thought that conversation went was maybe
Joel and Tess had not seen a bloater so
they couldn't confirm it okay rumor to
them I want to see Dave in the chat just
said Tess says something like I sure as
[__] hope not for bloaters which would
just simply they also haven't seen them
not that they don't exist right okay
yeah so that that makes sense
um but also love that conversation again
I'm a big fan of all the stuff of like
Ellie
learning everything through these two
people but uh with the spores
specifically
I think the reason I'm okay with it is
because that requires masks to be used
really frequently which ruins
performances like in every scene pretty
much and I think it's like a lot less
visually interesting as a TV show harder
to connect with characters especially
when you don't have the
implied or guaranteed sorry empathy when
you're actually playing the game um so
we have to find different ways to
connect to them so I think that would be
a problem
um I think it's also a little bit more
difficult to represent visually
yeah without a lot of probably annoying
cgg yeah I I agree with that Alana and
also and then you'd have to deal with
like well if the door opens does it
dissipate out the door can that clear
out an area like I I just don't know the
science of how spores could stay in an
area Airborne or if it would you know I
have no idea so I imagine yeah that
would be harder wasn't there like a
thing in the game where like someone's
mask cracks
wasn't there some significance to like
um someone else being immune to the
spores and and finding out that way I
think like I guess there's I think that
happens yeah I think it happens in the
second one yeah yeah oh [__] maybe I'm
not positive though maybe you're right
but like but you're right I've never I
actually haven't talked about like why
the spores aren't in the show either
um I just like the idea of it being so I
mean it makes it scarier right like I
think it's definitely scarier if it's
spores because then it's like well how
the [__] do you stay away from the air
essentially like totally and I think the
gameplay it works super well totally in
a video game World it totally works
you're right but in the show I do see
that like keeping them with masks on the
whole time it might be like a lot yeah I
think I I feel like that it's just they
don't want that to do that to their
actors and and make it less interesting
for us to watch which I'm I'm totally
cool with it maybe they'll bring it in
at some point like they'll do like you
know like if there's bloaters maybe they
let out spores and they're like this is
new yeah that would be cool yeah yeah I
think um
the other big difference in this episode
again from the games that I can recall
is uh the obviously just not presence of
military again I think that the not
shooting humans is just because it's a
little bit harder to watch from your
protagonist it's easier to make the
zombies the threat but I do feel like
we'll probably see a bit more of that
going forward I'm not expecting the show
to be completely void of human conflict
uh we've already seen hints of it
initially I mean Joel obviously killed
somebody pretty brutally in episode one
um Ellie's reaction to that was pretty
interesting she seemed to kind of enjoy
it in a strange way uh she's slightly
less innocent than game Ellie I feel
like
um so I'm expecting to see more of that
but did you guys feel like robbed in any
way of you know tet's death being
different or anything like that I mean
it made sense to me uh that they didn't
have quite so much fedra conflict right
outside as they're escaping because in
the game right the just the genre of
game it is you're dealing with these
areas you need to sell through and take
out or stealth by your opponents and
that's level after level after level and
I imagine in the series it would get
really repetitive if every building they
went to where every area they're going
through they're you know having to take
out so many fedra or so many infected
yeah um so that was the reason I thought
maybe they didn't have the federal
conflict worked in at this point in the
story but then it certainly I mean when
they got to the building where we know
that you know this is where tests like
we're you know this is where they were
supposed to hand off Ellie we know
what's going to happen to test if you
play the game I immediately thought oh
wait but there's been no fedra how are
they going to do this
um but with the episode being titled
infected it made sense that that's the
route they went but I didn't feel robbed
of anything I just thought oh this is a
you know different way to tell the story
we're still getting to the same end
point of you know Tessa's sacrifice just
a little different way I don't know how
about you Steve did you feel a little
robbed by the way that went down no I
think like you know if it if it all ends
up serving the same purpose for the
story and
for the you know to move the story along
then I'm not as long as it's done in a
way that works I'm cool with it you know
like uh and I think I feel that way
about anything they want to change at
this point it's like they're doing a
great job so far with the story with the
dialogue with the drama with the timing
with the editing the music like
everything's so good I'm kind of like
all right great I'm in their hands now
like if they want to change huge aspects
of the game
I mean I guess there's some things they
could do to truly ruin it but it seems
like we're
we're doing really well so far and from
people who have seen like other episodes
I hear it just gets better and better
pretty much so yeah I keep hearing like
Whispers that episode three is like
uh crazy in some way I don't know like I
know when I spoke to Troy he said
once you get to episode three you'll be
hooked which I found funny because the
implication was that I wouldn't be
hooked before that right you're not
already hooked did the show's so good
though
um but yeah people are like oh episode
three though so I'm I'm like extra
excited to see what happens in episode
three yeah give it yeah exciting yeah
did you have any any thoughts on the on
fedra not being quite as present I
maintain that I think video games and TV
at different mediums and and I think
it's the things that they're keeping
exactly the same are really just because
it's the best way to do it it's like
getting memed at this point but I do
think that the loss of us is one of the
best video game stories ever told I
think it's absolutely fantastic I
wouldn't say the best it's definitely
just up there with a bunch of other
great games with me so the things that
are exactly the same they're the same
because they were brilliant the first
time it's not like fan servicing that
like oh they said the same thing even if
we take it that way and it feels cool
because it feels personal to us but I
think it's more so that the things they
said were just the perfect thing to say
at that time that the way the shots were
which is perfect at the time there's no
need to actually change any of those
things
um so I think that the removal of fedra
again makes sense I don't think it works
as well in TV
um it it had to be there to make the
gameplay more interesting for us like
you said it's a combination between
Nathan Drake and 2 000 guys
and uh stealthing through buildings and
watching Joel shoot down a bunch of feds
is certainly not as interesting to watch
as it just becomes an action show at
that point right it's a lot of attention
too I think yeah and we're like doing
really well developing the characters
right now and I kind of want to spend
more time with that yeah and I again I
do hope that we have a lot of the human
conflicts I mean we know some of them
are coming based on some of the casting
um
and I think so far having that episode
mostly contained with just three people
and being so engrossed in it the whole
time and like the realization
um that that they didn't know that that
Ellie didn't know that she couldn't make
a noise and then being like Oh my God
shut up and me you're wanting to scream
at her to be like oh my God shut up and
then Joel steps on the [__] yeah
piece of glass and it's like no one's
safe yeah anyone can make a mistake and
I loved all of all of that and I think
you kind of lose some of the tension if
you're then in the middle of a firefight
afterwards too I agree I would agree
also during that part when he steps on
the glass did any of you think I
actually said out loud I was like throw
a bottle
[Laughter]
I I swear we have to have bottle
throwing I don't think we're gonna get
ships but we got the tape we got the
like electric tape and it was funny that
she was like go ahead while she's doing
the tape we found that really yeah
um so obviously directly related to that
this is the first episode where we had
our clickers
um for anyone who doesn't know they're
basically echolocation eating that's how
they figure out where to go and why they
don't run into walls because I saw a
bunch of TV viewers who haven't played
the games to be like how do they hit
themselves which I thought was very
funny
um because they basically have echo
location I love the sound design with
these I believe it's the same voice
actors as the games shout out Misty Lee
no way oh there you go that's awesome
it sounds so cool they look fantastic
um just as terrifying as ever walking
through that building like I had trouble
playing The Last of Us when I first
played it because it made me feel so
tense that I would have to put the
controller down and take breaks like it
really the tension because it's not just
horror it's tension and the fact that
the show encapsulated that in some of
the same moments that I felt that in the
game was like it's so tense well and
then when they're running at like in the
game when they like pick up speed and
they start taking off after you like I
thought they captured that in the show
perfectly like I think it was really
well directed start to oh so good it it
really well done yeah the only thing
it's got to be a horror show too right
like you can't avoid it totally yeah I
mean that's a it's a terrifying Waltz
the the other thing that got me was um
test did not get ripped apart
yeah well because Okay so
the thing that the Creator said about
the tendril things is that that is how
they're like infecting how they infect
other people is with that like the
tendrils so if the tendrils make contact
with you you're screwed essentially so
the click is just on as aggressive I
guess they're not I guess yeah ripping
people to shreds yeah well they were
talking there was an interview where
they talked about the aggressiveness
at the end though yeah which was with a
runner I believe
but yeah they were talking about you
know why do why do we assume that the
infection and the spread of the fungus
has to be violent is it only violent if
people resist
um right which is kind of how they were
talking about the kiss at the end
um but yeah Alana to your point I mean
clickers are very violent in the game
and you do get ripped to shreds if you
don't hit all the right buttons in just
the right order
um so that is interesting that that's
you know and I can't remember in the
game if that's
if that if she gets bit in that scene
because I mean they have it they have
the scene right before where they
um were the soldiers the federal
soldiers come by and both Joel and Tess
get a green not infected so it has to
happen between then and there so right I
assumed it happened in that clickering
counter but yes you're absolutely right
then I figured it probably wouldn't I
think it was the museum right yeah the
one before it I think that yeah no it
was the museum I think it had to be that
um because I don't think she's had any
other encounter with them and again we
we do see several applicant interactions
there
um they get away certainly I wouldn't
have if I had done that stuff in the
video game there's no way I was making
it out of that building life but you
gotta change the stakes a little so it
was just an interesting change that I
think
maybe like the tension's still there if
them needing to be quiet but maybe makes
the click as slightly less scary not
that losing your life isn't scary but
like I was just so scared of them maybe
and we just didn't see it it was off
camera
secret shiv yeah she was going through
those drawers we just didn't see it
happen but it definitely is like making
you remember playing the game and how
intense the game was and how like I
really didn't expect the game to be as
terrifying as it ended up being oh yeah
because you're like well this is just
gonna be like a well we're gonna fight
zombies or whatever but it can't be
like also a super scary game right but
but I remember being terrified of the
game and then feeling that way in the
museum scene and remembering how scary
it was to play those totally scenes yeah
they're doing a great job a bunch of
people in chat saying different things
someone said
Tess wasn't bitten she was just
scratched I'm pretty I feel like she was
definitely bitten uh someone said they
didn't break up she was already infected
well I knew that at the end I knew
that's why they didn't rip her pot at
the end but the clickers in the museum
in theory would have yeah I'm pretty
sure she had a bite mark on her neck I I
love honestly that they what they did
with the bite between Tess and Ellie as
well where you could see Ellie's healing
and very good not I thought that was a
beautiful addition to the series that I
didn't especially because Joel still
didn't seem to really trust it
um right yeah I loved that that was that
was so well done they're doing all these
things that they do in other shows and
horror movies and stuff but they're
doing it in like a really well done way
like they're taking time to represent
these things in a way that isn't like
hand holdy it's very like that's what
would happen in that moment like you
look at an at a bite and you can tell
how far along in the infection you are
at this point in the show you know uh
for the characters who have been
surviving in that world and then Ellie's
version of it being like not spread was
a perfect visual way to show what that
looks like and what it'll look like in
the show going forward too
yeah and it was it was great to
establish the time frame of like how
long it'll actually take
um in in the TV show which is not long
like if you get bitten you turn pretty
quick but it's nice to have that
introduction in episode two I'm sure
that's a question a lot of people were
wondering about and like if they had
they had mentioned nobody lost this long
with Ellie saying that beforehand but
seeing the comparison and yeah I thought
I don't that wasn't the game and I loved
that the like showing Joel both of them
was was just so good but yeah I mean
there are people in chat also saying
that they think she was bitten by a
runner in the museum rather than a
clicker um maybe yeah but again it
doesn't really matter just a point that
I thought was interesting was like uh
The Click is that brutal um they can't
see right so what do they know really
are they are they tearing people apart
or not it doesn't really matter because
ultimately I thought those scenes were
were still very good and they were still
really scary and
that that whole action scene
um
just on my toes you know on the edge of
the seat whatever the quote is that they
say on the on the seat of my toes White
Knuckles
and yeah the sound design I thought was
fantastic like the design across the
board for the show I think is just like
so incredible and I think It ultimately
ended up leading to test probably dying
a lot sooner than a lot of the TV going
audiences would have expected
um but like even knowing that it was
coming to me it felt like probably
like one of the most impactful TV deaths
I think I've seen in ages like yeah
especially because she was so such a
good character they developed her very
well in the show and you're like well it
seems like her and Joel are like a
perfect team yeah and I wanted her to be
there for Ellie rather than her having
to stay with Joel who at this point is
like a grumpy piece of [__] I know but
but you also want to get to like the
Joel and Ellie like relationship
building stuff totally because it seems
like that's really where the emotional
core of the show is gonna be and so we
gotta get there you know I also felt
like it was super impactful in terms of
Joel's character development that Tess
was like look I'm making this sacrifice
so that you can get this one spark of
hope we might have for Humanity to where
she needs to go
knowing what's going to happen at the
end of the scene or the season no
spoilers knowing everything yeah knowing
where this is going I was like
well yeah I mean is there a chance they
deviate from that in some way you think
it would be an uproar they could yeah
it's again such a good ending and it's
yeah it is kind of nice that we don't
know exactly how things are gonna play
out like yeah I love that yeah I love
that that it's it's so good and is doing
things that we like very very well but
isn't necessarily going to give me
everything like I don't know what to
expect from Next Episode I'm not already
like well at this point
it's like it's nice to not have that
exact pop right out in front of me well
I guess we gotta get to Joel's brother
at this point yeah yeah we're gonna get
there because we we're on the edge of
our seat
yes
of course
um and yeah again ending with that kiss
which you kind of already touched on
like I just thought it was so gross and
felt a little bit weird about it uh I
think
I think what it did do well is a very
good job of
um
trying to
make them creepy and disgusting
um
in a way that you don't often see with
zombies like a lot of zombie TV shows
have told very similar stories about
humanity and I think often we see a
zombie running at someone and they look
kind of scary doing that and having the
tendrils come out of the mouth makes
them unsettling in a way that is unusual
for zombie TV shows which yeah we
haven't seen it we haven't seen it so it
makes you a little more uncomfortable
with them
um I think the reason I didn't like it
is that the choice for it to be a kiss
specifically I feel like just kind of
like maybe downplayed Tess's death for
me a little bit like it yeah it was
almost comical in a in a strange way
that I was like definitely gross it gets
a laugh not a like a oh [__] yeah maybe
if you've done it too right right if
you've done it do her bite I would have
been like oh gross cool yeah because it
was a kiss
yeah it just took me out of the scene a
little I think um yeah and it's one of
those things violating yeah right which
I think is the good part like it yeah
they made it violating it yeah it didn't
need to make it any more unsettling than
like I mean I don't know I guess if we
need a visual representation of how
spores are like or not spores whatever
they they're calling it The
Sudafed or whatever
you have Robitussin yeah
so Simon
mushrooms it has to be a visual there it
is yeah there has to be a visual
representation of like how it infects
you I guess because I mean the bite is
very zombie we've seen it before but is
there a way is there like a faster way
or is there like a different way to
infect people and I want to see one go
for that Amos next time I hope it's not
a kiss every time
what about the kids every time yeah
again the anus go and make it it's like
they just touched it it doesn't look
like those Avatar things
yeah it uh someone in chat said I have
trouble with the infected being
intelligent enough to decide that they
should go for the kiss instead of Simply
biting or eating and that is also a good
point I think I think that that is a
little bit odd that they had to like
think to kiss her yeah but I think the
thing we're not talking about is is that
like she was already infected and so
maybe there's a way for like the you
know they're trying to communicate they
could they can already tell she's like
one of them so maybe it's like let's
just get this over with oh but that's
for sure what it was yeah I guess this
fungus kind of stuff isn't that dumb
like they like I said the the actual
fungus that it's based on does know to
fly the host somewhere warm so that it
can Thrive like they do overtake your
brain
um it's just that the brain only has the
goal of survival which in this case is
like adding to the network that's why
when the sun was like going over them on
the ground they were like reacting they
were wiggling to the sun oh yeah I did
think that noticed that yeah that was
strange too
um but very creepy creepy yeah so so
yeah they need the heat no they need the
Sun or whatever Also earlier you guys
were talking about
um the theory that the infection started
in wheat or like flour or something yeah
and some people were talking about how
in the first episode
um Joel refuses to eat right biscuit and
they eat eggs instead they never make
the pancakes yeah he doesn't get his
birthday cake and Ellie or uh Sarah uh
refuses the biscuits at the neighbor's
house yeah so are they saying that like
that's how it spread like it spread
through just literally flour yep that's
crazy I love it I love it yeah I even
saw people like be like that doesn't
make sense when you cook
the flour when you cook the biscuit
shouldn't it have died and because I was
like let me look into this
um yeah the answer is no if there's
fungi in a lot of things and you bake it
or whatever generally still like 20 of
it will won't be able to survive isn't
that how yeast works yeah that's exactly
how yeast works so like we could still
get yeast infections that's still a
thing that happens to humans that's
basically based on the same premise like
it it uh unless you put something in a
microwave which kills everything I'm
pretty sure oh okay uh if you're baking
they could put everyone in a microwave
in this show well they tried with the
bombs that's true that's true
I mean that yeah which again I I also
love that the the timing of that of you
know going past that bomb crater and
talking about how they tried to bomb
everything and the way that they're
giving us the exposition I think is
fantastic like I just think it's it's so
well done I love the pacing of this
episode too again the fact that it's
like a journey of three people
um yeah I did really really enjoy this
episode and the the one performance
thing that I didn't love that stood out
to me is the only performance thing I
didn't like this whole show so far that
no one else has mentioned so it could
just be me it was just the way that
Ellie like put a hand on her head
and then made a comment that was like
they told me not to tell anyone and then
I'm telling the first people that I meet
um that's the only time that I've been
like I just didn't really buy that
performance like that to me just felt a
little bit odd and I think and this is
like I'm so sure that this issue that
I'm having has come from me reading so
many comments of other people saying it
so it made me hype aware this episode
unfortunately is
um Ellie swearing almost every uh
sentence this episode stood out to me a
little but again I think that that's
just because I'd seen other people do it
or comment on it so then I noticed it
yeah
um you know swearing is totally normal
who cares in this world I swear all the
time but the frequency of it I just kept
kept noticing for some reason this time
is like something that's like do you
have to say [__] fabulous could you
not say yeah I'm good like it's a lot of
attitude but again I I that's a really
minor thing that I think might have been
influenced by the greater internet
unfortunately
how do you feel about Bella Ramsay's
Ellie so far in general I I really
really like Bella Ramsay I think she's
definitely like spunky hottie um I I
really like her performance uh
definitely doesn't seem to have as much
innocence as uh game Ellie which I think
is fine so far but is going to be a
little bit interesting going forward
when you know we have to have Joel
really kick in to kind of father mode
when he has to become a big fatherly
figure you kind of need to have a little
girl who needs that whereas she's not
acting like someone who needs that at
all so um so far love it but I'm hoping
that we like see her break at some point
see a little bit more softness at some
point like everything that's happening
thus far I buy and I'm I love the
costing for absolutely everybody I think
they're all amazing
um such good performances it's it's so
good but I hope to see like at some
point a little bit more innocent
somewhere so that we can like justify
the need to want to help her
um
because that has to be the whole Crux of
the story but we have a lot of episodes
to go to get there how about you yeah
that's another one of those like where I
feel like I I trust the show Runners and
I trust where they're going with it and
uh you know if they want to portray
Ellie is like a little bit more of a
firecracker
um
that's cool I mean you know it is a
little bit like come on I mean she's a
kid like
she like why you know she doesn't really
behaving like a kid at all she I think
she kind of caught though like I I kind
of get the impression of like
she's very important in this world right
and she's around hardened adults so I
think she's just trying to act like an
adult to act like she's yeah that's see
that's what I'm thinking too so like I'm
thinking they're giving her this really
hard exterior but we're gonna get the
emotional breakdown with the Joel uh and
Ellie connection stuff and then we'll
see yeah and also she's an orphan yeah
and she's an orphan who's been raised in
this apocalypse yeah so that all seems
to be like would make her way more
hardened than kids that we yeah but it
might be a facade and we'll get more of
that dramatic uh that more emotional
um you know because she again she's a
kid I think we need to remember there
needs to be like um you know it raises
the stakes that it's a kid you know
truly because and the fact that she's so
important is already enough to make the
stakes up there but
um you know once we get the
father-daughter dynamic I think that's
when we'll start to see that stuff I
just can't read her Ellie well yet yeah
no yeah
amazing actress and I loved her in Game
of Thrones
um but to me I I've spent so much time
with game Ellie that it's a little it's
a little tricky for me right now I need
to spend more time with her Ellie to
really I think feel close to her and
again and I mean at this point she's
she's not letting anyone close to her so
I think we're feeling exactly what we're
meant to be feeling yeah I think I think
you're probably right and and again
because you know in the game you're the
one who's looking after her you are
doing those actions so you you yourself
are creating that Bond as well that's a
lot harder on TV as well and it was nice
to see the hotel scene of her being
silly that I think was very similar to
the way that it happened in the game as
well with with Ashley Johnson
um like that you get to see kind of more
of a childish side of her was really
really nice uh I think I do think it all
makes sense for right now even again the
swearing thing I know she swears a ton
in the game too um I think that that
that is all like a an act of somebody
trying to seem adult and mature and seem
like they've got it together through all
they've been through they'd be hardened
as well I just um yeah they've
definitely got a diff a different
approach that they they have to have a
different approach to make us have a ton
of empathy when they don't have the
benefit of us looking after her because
we're not playing it
um so I think you're probably right not
currently concerned about that more like
excited to see how they do it and and
where it goes we've got a lot of
episodes left because yeah I mean we
have played the game so like we kind of
like are expecting certain Beats and
character you know beats but but I think
we're we're in the mercy we're at the
mercy of the show Runners and the show
seems to kind of deviate a little from
the game already so I guess we just kind
of have to like wait and see right like
we don't know where this is I'm with
Alana I'm excited by it I can't wait to
see where that performance goes next
what they do with the character
um and yeah I mean I'm honestly I'm
loving this series so far I think out of
all the video game adaptations I've ever
seen only this series and Castlevania
well taking the mechanics of the game
and translating it into the series in a
natural way like I feel like all of us
got super excited when the furniture got
moved to move out the door and when Tess
had to squeeze through the thing to come
and unlock the door from the other side
like that stuff being seamlessly
incorporated into it's not distracting
yeah yeah it just works so uh can I ask
you guys which which of the episodes did
you like more at this point did you have
a preference for episode one or episode
two
uh questions yeah I I think I like the
second episode better uh
but but I think mostly because like um I
hadn't watched the first episode it took
me like a week to watch to finally watch
the first episode and uh everyone was
like hyping it up like this was like the
most amazing pilot ever and I was like
what really I mean I I love TV and I
I've seen some good pilots in my day so
um yeah you came from the hype of
everyone enjoying it and that was from
people who expected it to be bad thanks
exactly
right right and and uh I was pleasantly
surprised at how well they handled like
even with um Pedro playing Joel like
it's just perfect casting like we were
just talking about perfect casting but
um but I didn't think it was like the
best pilot ever of anything and I was a
bit rushed with my one thing yeah it's
good it's really good and if you've
never played the game you're in for a
[__] ride right and you know it from
the get-go but knowing the game so well
it's like okay nothing's really
surprising me right now like this is a
thing we we've seen shows where a zombie
apocalypse happens like how are they
going to bring us into this world how
are they going to develop the characters
what's going to happen the way they did
it was I thought they did a great job
but it wasn't anything we had never
really seen before oh yeah I mean I
loved it but I think that that's all
probably totally fine yeah yeah I just
wasn't blown away like so many people
were but I I definitely enjoyed the
second episode more how about you Trish
oh it's a tough call for me
um the the hotel scene I know we didn't
talk too much about the hotel but having
that water and having them have to go
through that water just was so like it
in both the game and in the series it
made me so uncomfortable and I thought
they did a great job with that but for
me as an Australian I went oh crocodiles
I went oh corpsey fungus yeah true
friends
um but yeah I for me it's you know there
were some there were I would say that
moment in the second episode and the
impact of Tessa's death not necessarily
how it happened but the impact of Tess's
death are both super standouts for me
but for me if I had to pick one I think
I would say the pilot
um because it was our introduction to
what this world in the series is going
to look like and we got so much more
Sarah yeah which I think is so integral
to Joel's character yeah and I really I
just as someone who's played the games I
loved getting to know Sarah that much
more I think it made the beginning so
much it was great so much stronger and
hit home and that intro where they're
just talking about well basically if a
fungal pandemic hits we're all screwed I
love that it grounded it in reality for
us especially just us all coming out of
a global pandemic ish it was weird like
it just it made it so real and so
terrifying and it's exactly what I
wanted out of the series so yeah for me
I would say pilot totally fair I think I
like two more again I think the Pilot's
fantastic as well I do really like it
because I loved the opening of two more
than I liked the opening of one I just
thought that that that well it honestly
gave me chills the scenery really got me
um and I think probably what it is is
actually just that the ending of episode
two hit me harder than the ending of
episode one and that's probably because
the ending of episode one
is something that we did all know was
going to happen and didn't necessarily
lead into what was next in a super
interesting way whereas now I'm like oh
[__] it's just the two of them
what does that look like and so I'm I'm
super excited for next week like it's
I'm annoyed that I can't binge watch
this show I know no I'm the same way I
watched it today and I was like man I
don't want to watch it like this yeah I
want to go right into the next one damn
it yeah I'll be the odd I'll be the
Oddball out and say I love that they're
doing the weekend release I miss having
like event TV I agree with that that's
with my friends like we are right now
and hypothesize and yeah and Theory deep
on this it is really exciting it makes
it so much more fun yeah I definitely
agree with that like I just I want to
keep watching it which is a sign of a
great show but I love that we can do
this and like I'm doing this every week
with different people and like seeing
the whole internet by a storm take it on
a Sunday night and be like oh what do we
think of this like seeing the flower
Theory pop up I didn't know that until I
made a video about episode one and I saw
it in the comments and I was like oh my
God it is yeah that's it is really
really fun to get to do and to get to
talk to people about it do you guys
think that they'll do like the first
season is the first game the second
season is the second game and by the
time the third season's ready we'll have
a third game I don't know it's it's hard
to say if they'll do second season that
way because
Bella Ramsay has to age a lot great
Point great I'm just not no isn't she
how old is she in real life I think
she's 19. but like I feel like when I
was 19 to
I don't know 25 I looked the same like I
don't think I really changed at all yeah
um because how old's Ellie in the second
game
that's a great relationship that's a
great question but she's definitely not
like a little kid anymore
oh my God the first result that comes up
is when I type in how old is is Jenna
Ortega
that's hilarious because Bella Ramsay
might actually be the right age to be
Ellie in the second season I don't know
in the second season
I think we just see a much more hardened
like grown-up because of everything
she's been through Ellie in the second
game too
yeah I think I mean it's a you can do a
lot with makeup okay so she's 19 and
Ellie is 19 in the last yes okay Bella
Ramsey is currently 19 playing a 14 year
old and Ellie is 19 in part two I mean
they might be ready to to do it by the
time season two rolls around them I also
heard I mean I don't know if either of
you have heard this
um but I had also heard that
um they didn't want the series to expand
the story beyond what the games tell oh
okay theories will cover the same so I
don't know if they do game one season
one game two season two I don't know
that there would be a season three it
might just be done there because that's
told the story that's the great thing
about working with HBO like the fact
that Watchmen was that successful it was
just one season one and done yeah I
think that they maybe won't pressure
people to make more seasons and they're
ready to necessarily but the downside of
that is that they could also just remove
the whole thing apparently whenever they
don't want to yeah if they want so I
do they still do that I hope so if they
do Steven's the one that has yeah I will
have it
I'll have the Blu-rays because I love it
it's like a lot of physical media
on Earth I wasn't going to say anything
but
um so yeah I guess like in closing my
last thing was just like I love how how
scary brutal hostile and tense this show
is it's [__] Ferry on the on the tip
of my seat I think it's what I said on
the seat of my toes I'm very very you
know
um enthralled with it performance is a
fantastic the set design is blowing my
mind I just think the way the world
looks is incredible and I I can't wait
to see more I'm really enjoying it Trish
how are you feeling so far loving it I
am such a big fan I'm honestly I'm
stoked to have event TV and I'm stoked
that it's the last of us because the
last of us is my favorite zombie
Universe nobody tell the walking dead
but it's true
um and I'm I I just I love seeing it on
I mean I want to say the big screen but
it's not the middle screen when it's
home it feels like a big screen right
the couch right it does feel like thank
you Steve that's a very great way to say
it it feels like a big cinematic
theatrical experience that could go
watch in a movie theater because it is
that epic and I'm just I'm loving it I
love the small things they're
incorporating from the game mechanics
wise that are just little Easter eggs to
the players I love when you put the
shots side by side and in the first
episode there was even the street signs
were exactly the same as the screenshot
from the game like oh cool you can just
tell that there's so much love there for
the original Source material and as a
fan of the series as a fan of the game
series the franchise I should say I'm in
love with the series
Steve how about you absolutely Echo
everything you guys said I just I'm
happy that there's a video game like a
good video game adaptation happening and
it's on a network where you can say [__]
a few times yep and get real violent
because that's what the show demands
like if AMC was doing it I'd be a little
concerned you didn't want the CW to do
it
really in school yeah and Joel's like
25.
that's like when ABC did Rocky Horror
remember that yeah
yeah well thank you both so much for
joining me this week this week it is
super fun to get to chat to everybody by
the show thanks to everybody in chat um
Trish where can people find you on the
internet
um people want to find me on the
internet I'm that girl Trish with no I
and the girl so just that GRL Trish on
all the places except for twitch and
YouTube where it's just my name Trisha
Hershberger thank you Alana for having
me this was so fun of course uh Steve
how about you where are you uh I'm on
the internet's at Steve's there goes on
all the socials and that's that's my
thing I do I promote all the things I do
there so just check those out I guess I
will leave a link in the description to
both of your things actually send me a
DM and I'll just put whatever links you
want in the description perfect thank
you for having me yeah what you both
said you wanted to I was like
all right let's go easy and honestly I I
don't get to work with Trisha too much
often these days and I love it when I
get to it was wonderful doing this with
you Trisha doesn't it remind you of the
days when we would review things yes
except for Alana's much more prepared
than you and I ever were when we
reviewed things on the internet yeah I
doubt it I
Steve probably half paid attention to
whatever we were watching and half
messed around and then we filmed a
review well it's hard not to be
engrossed in this show okay don't credit
me credit card
um everybody watching I'm gonna go live
on Twitch right after ending this
because my plan you guys I'm very
excited about this is to stream the game
exactly in line with the show
so
I'm gonna get to the end of episode two
and then next week and then three yeah
that's the point I thought that would be
super fun so I'll do this this podcast
and then I'll jump over to Twitch and do
the gameplay so I will jump over there
in a second uh thank you guys for
joining me thank you everybody for
watching
I will see you all next time